what's all this it's an after-work hang
just trying to turn up as it were we got
snacks games decorations chairs
it's chairs cool maybe we can mill
around and small talk about how some of
us are big lying liars who lie all the
time like a bunch of liars Rosa I don't
think that's good party combo maybe we
should just name our favorite sailing
not I'll start the bowline how about
some tunes cool merry-go-round music
yeah John Philip Sousa the Skrillex of
his day come on people hit the dance
floor have a good time why is no one
having a good time I specifically
requested it Jenna why'd you dancing I
can't I'm in the middle of a feud with
that's not a knife guy from Crocodile
Dundee he's being a real [__] fine
I guess I'll just stop the party I
didn't realize it ever started enough I
tried to make this fun I even learned
what Skrillex was sorry you're all
miserable but guess what so am i I'm
exhausted all the time I never see my
husband the late-night NPR programming
pure garbage I'm done trying we can all
be miserable together
it's too tight
loser I feel like when are you doing
late it or no I told you I'm a sumo
wrestler after he lost the weight I take
it we're having a party knew there was
something I forgot to tell you sorry no
no it's fine why should you guys tell me
you're gonna have an enormous party I
didn't tell you I was gonna be quietly
working in my room that's a good point
yeah yeah I guess we're even if you need
me I'll definitely be awake because I
won't be able to sleep because of the
party you know so alright my family is
very non-confrontational my parents
method of problem-solving is to kind of
keep everything bottled up and just
subtly hint at what's bothering them and
after 36 years they are still divorced
are you kidding I'm not done yet
wait this fits in the palm of my hand
you haven't blown them up enough why
have you chosen brown and gray balloons
they match the carpet what is that it is
your birthday Pierce Damon a fact not
even an exclamation point this is more
professional it's not like she
discovered a cure for cancer I can't
believe I've added this looks are you
trying to hurt my feelings because if so
you are succeeding fortunately my
feelings regenerated twice the speed of
a normal Lance okay good then have you
collected the money from everyone I am
working on it how much do you have six
dollars that's how much you and I
contributed dammit Jim I said I was
working on you thought you could
distract me with a record deal please
I'm already represented by my mom god
you're a turd well this turd is your
best friend's future husband
doink hey
[Applause]
tell your mother I said I never loved
you and that your whole family is a
bunch of friggin never have I ever slept
with a guy broken his heart hired him to
play at my wedding
stolen a legally binding contract from
him jumped on a bar dumped booze on
everyone falling off the bar probably
giving myself a concussion and a
permanent scar I have ever it is
officially after midnight so I can now
say whatever I want tonight was awesome
and I loved hanging out with you dorks
you know the word dork is actually a
Celtic word meaning lumbus slightly I'm
trying so hard I need to get more tips
all right
come on no this is a pacifist protest
had enough nice yeah oh my god Andy I am
so sorry
Oh psyche blood capsules what yeah I
wanted to shock you into expressing your
anger and that way my nose is broken the
hospital feel good happy birthday
surprise this doesn't look good
what you have a cake you have a
delicious cake with your name spelled
correctly told you you haven't heard him
though you don't hear a theme you see it
why is there a chicken on my cake that's
the best part that represents a pillow
or a television our theme if you will
because the fun part is you get to
decide on an hour of television or an
hour of napping that's our theme huh
yeah oh yes okay good so what's it gonna
be Kapoor can she pick a half hour of
each no oh then pick TV take a nap no no
no watching TV at work is really cool
but nothing good is all right now Bonnie
how is on you know I have been watching
TV all week I choose now all right okay
nap it is everyone out get out we're
gonna be eating cake at our desks let's
go move it let's go Coco Coco come on
ahem this is for you
and it's a happy birthday tell thank you
okay you've got one hour ticks it asleep
hmm
great cake Thanks
birthday time is over now go make up for
all the work you missed when you were
taking your nap many happy returns
halt I thought you already left yeah
closed a couple of cases and had to
finish up the paperwork also I wanted to
thank you again for giving us this
half-day yes of course I understand how
important these extravaganzas are I'm
sure you'll have a hoot oh yeah
although I'm sure our hoots pale in
comparison to the hoots that you had
back in the day I bet things got Supes
hoots actually I wasn't privy to those
events as a gay black detective I was
excluded from most social gatherings you
guys off the blazing golf yeah no I do
not
yeah golf sucks I know that wasn't the
point of your story those guys were
jerks
yes but I do envy the camaraderie they
shared I've always wanted the Josh
arrived with my peers so you've never
joshed around with anyone never but go
have fun with the squad really just Rob
for me welcome to Chateau boy al Eleanor
told me to keep the place clean but I
don't care
mommy's out of town and we're gonna
party you call your ex-wife mommy not
consciously this will do just fine
you brought pineapple well the fanny was
deep I am prepared for any vacation
situations I've got a bottle opener
sunscreen inflatable neck pillow wait
are we having undue tight Gina you ready
to party or why don't mind if I uh uh
whoa you two shots behind linetti what
up party people you know how I'm always
saying it ain't a real party till your
boss shows up unexpectedly well it's a
party what are you talking about
hello party people Peralta told me to
say that yeah I did
ain't no party like a captain Holt party
cuz the captain Holt party is a total
surprise to everyone I think I left my
wallet in your house who cares right
here
that's mr. James Albert keys keys stop
forgetting things I didn't forget them
right here mr. James Halpert I'm so
sorry wait idiot Oh miss Matt what are
you doing hey I have a question who do
you think is really the best salesman in
this office
stupid question obviously mr. James
you